but first if you're at an airport over
the weekend you may have seen American
troops on the move leaving their
families on their way to the Middle East
now just a month ago not one in a
hundred Americans was thinking about
Iran now suddenly we are on the brink of
war in Washington that is considered an
upgrade indeed a massive improvement
it's harder to get rich and powerful in
Washington during peacetime so our
leaders have a built-in bias for war and
so they descended on television studios
over the weekend to describe and detail
the kind of violence they're prepared to
wreak on a country very few of them know
anything about here for example is
Senator Lindsey Graham of South Carolina
if the Iranians hit American targets and
American interests and American allies
will respond militarily if they hit us
again then I would not want I would not
want to be working in an Iranian oil
field because I think the president is
determined to bring this regime to its
knees if they continue to be provocative
I mean while the Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo assured reporters at the u.s.
Sikhs quote de-escalation with Iran and
then just moments later suggested the
u.s. might bomb dozens of sites inside
Iran itself president Trump is saying
that there are 52 sites than the US
would target if Iran retaliates how is
that consistent with what you say is
your message of de-escalation entirely
consistent threatening to bomb mainland
Iran the Iranian leadership needs to
understand that attacking Americans is
not cost-free to take a terrorist off
the battlefield does not increase the
risk of Terror the risk of terrorism is
increased by appeasement the risk of
Terror is increased by appeasement it's
a good line and it may be true probably
is true of course the risk of Terror is
also increased by bombing other people's
countries that is also indisputably true
it's hard to remember now but as
recently as last week most people didn't
consider Iran an imminent threat Iranian
saboteurs were not committing acts of
terror in our cities oh but our leaders
tell us they were about to any second
and that's why we struck first what's so
striking is how many people appear to
accept this uncritically just the other
day you remember our Intel agencies were
considered politically tainted and
suspect
certainly on this show they are were and
will be for quite some time if you don't
mind these are the people who invented
excuses to spy in the Trump campaign
purely because they didn't like Donald
Trump's foreign policy views and they're
the ones who pretended he was a Russian
agent in order to keep him from
governing remember that Russia gate our
friends at the insult community did that
and by the way these are the same people
who lied about a rocks weapons of mass
destruction way back in 2002 and by
doing that got us into an utterly
pointless war that dramatically weakened
our country the people pushing conflict
with Iran are the same people who did
that it seems like about 20 minutes ago
we were denouncing these very people as
the deep state and pledging never to
trust them again without verification
but now for some reason we do seem to
trust them implicitly and completely in
fact we believe whatever they tell us no
matter how outlandish Iran did 9/11
they're telling us oh okay didn't know
that 15 of the 19 hijackers were from
Sunni Saudi Arabia none were from Shiite
Iran but if you say so mr. unnamed CIA
official I'm happy to send my kid to the
Middle East a week after Christmas on
the basis of your anonymous done
verified leaked to the New York Times
you've earned my trust through years of
lying to me that appears to be our
position now that maybe all this will
turn out fine in the end we're certainly
praying for it we love this country but
in the meantime pardon the skepticism